like men value purity more
like yeah
yeah like they they want something like
that they want a girl that hasn't slept
with like too many guys basically yes so
like but you guys want women that have
the experience yet you still want that
purity so where is that that doesn't
make sense exactly that's not going to
be i agree with you it doesn't make
sense yeah you can't you can you can't
have a pure woman that hasn't
experienced anything that doesn't make
sense why does someone that exp has had
experience make them not pure
like what defines purity in your eyes
i define that for me as me as an
individual me as me as me yeah you um
i don't look at i don't look at people
in that
i don't know
i'm talking about i'm talking about me
as an individual well it's like it's
it's genetics like they're biologically
predispositioned to want a woman that's
pure because they want to ensure
paternity so so biologically like it's
the same way like we want a guy that
makes more money than us because before
we needed a guy that was more competent
than us to take care of us and like who
wants to be the guy that you're more
competent than like that's not
you want to feel protected yeah yeah and
that's like like like that would be like
men calling us gold diggers it's like us
like saying to them oh it's wrong for
you wanting a pure girl like they're
biologically wired to want that
you know no question like can most guys
get it which is why back in the day yeah
chastity and purity was
you know it was um it was it was a thing
a woman who was a virgin was a thing
wait i have a question would you would
you date a girl that was a virgin and
like wait till you were married with her
would you want to i would
if you were
single and like what 20 something would
you would you wait
like to have sex with somebody yes
probably if i was like in my 20s yes
because now
now i've experienced more the world you
know i mean i'm like do you know what
i've noticed so they always i was
talking to do you know donovan sharp is
yeah
so on his show like he was saying like
the
like
men
like want like the ideal is a virgin
right but what i've noticed is like high
value guys like don't like seem to care
about that because they'll over a
certain age like guys are just like
whatever like they don't want a girl
that's for the streets but they don't
even like
we don't that's why i've noticed like
those guys don't really end up with like
like virgins a lot of the times like
even like the celebrities like they
could have whoever and kanye was just
dating like who yeah
and he married kim karda but like it
just seems like over a certain level
unattainable
um it's an unattainable dichotomy
between
someone who is not a whole but not a
virgin yeah
yeah yeah it doesn't actually make yeah
if you look at it seriously it's that
guys want a woman who's not a whole but
not a virgin yeah do you know what i
mean it's always like they don't have
this it doesn't make sense really do you
know what i mean like if we're honest
with ourselves like they have the
experience of a hoe
but then you know they're close to the
version but if you're closer to the
virginity scale a guy will think ah
okay i can take her and kind of mold her
into what i kind of want yeah but we
don't want a full woman who's for the
streets that's interesting what defines
for the streets like is it because of
her experience you know who the women
are for the shoes
only because
go on like a hole in it like somebody's
no i'm talking about experience so
basically if a woman's got more than
like
careful
be careful thirty thirty men that she's
left with i'm like i feel like a lot of
people define experience for how maybe
like because i feel like you can't be
experienced with men like you can know
what you're doing and everything with
like three women
or maybe even as a girl okay
three men maybe i could be experienced i
want women that are experienced no thank
you men want women who are semi-expert
as i'm saying
it's an unattainable yeah it generally
is an unattainable thing
but the thing is women want men
who have been experienced would you want
a virgin there's a man to me no no but
yeah but he doesn't know what he's
talking about based on
no but i get that but generally there's
a woman want a man who doesn't know what
he's doing
based on experience like what i want
from a man in general like as a whole
like it's not based on experience like
how men would say like you know they
want like a more
pure woman
like that's not my
standard
do you know what i mean so what do you
want is do you want a man who's had
experience in the bedroom or not it
doesn't like it doesn't really matter to
me like you want a virgin so if you had
a man who was a virgin didn't know what
the hell you didn't know where your
clitoris was in the way yeah like he
didn't know nothing
bring it to the extreme i think she just
means like you know not someone that's
like necessarily like a professional in
bed you know maybe someone that you know
like he's been around the town yeah he
doesn't even but not necessarily
because i thought it was like because
you would find a man who had more
experience yeah but it doesn't even
matter you would find
if there's a guy like and i know this
goes against like what the man of sphere
says but if there's a guy and i know he
slept with like a bunch of girls i know
i'm like i'm good on that i'm no but
what if he's got 100 women that he slept
with but you know not one of them i
don't know them um i probably
you good how would you even know about
it
no but what if you had that conversation
wouldn't you have that conversation
you're absolutely behind i'm nosy i
always ask myself
um
but he's saying listen i love you like
we're in a relationship this is you
i would be okay because here's my thing
i
i get very like
nervous so like like with the guys
because like what are the odds you can
go from like that many girls to one like
i you know what i mean like that would
make me like more skeptical i don't
think it would like write them off but i
just think that you're creatures of
habit so if your habit is sleeping with
like that many girls in a year like what
are the odds you can go from that to
zero like
emotional connection with them because
you found you yeah am i that like
i still think men are biologically wired
a certain way so i still think you are a
product of your habits just like i think
like i understand vice versa like if
you're with a girl that has like cheated
in every relationship to like like you
know she might do it again if the guy's
used to sleeping around like what are
the odds he's gonna stop your resume
your resume yeah yeah
right and probably what you're going to
do in the future yeah right yeah i mean
so so it's more like like i'll be
attracted to those guys but i'm always
like oh god like
like you you would i always say i always
say don't ruin my mouth
you have experience yeah that's true
because we're attracted to like then
otherwise because with experience it
brings confidence it brings a certain
swagger it means a certain
energy do you understand
exactly so
so women generally don't they're not
attracted to virgin men
i'm muted
how many haircuts
so she's sick on the fact that you can
go get water if you want to go
do you agree that women are generally
attracted to men with experience yeah i
would say that yeah because it's just
because
it's just like a like you said a
confidence they have a little swagger
they have about them that they're going
to walk into a room is like yeah i know
i can get you right because of my track
record so i ain't about to shy away from
you exactly
but women aren't generally attracted to
men
with no experience
men attracted to women with less
experience yeah if that makes sense
and i'm talking about for a long-term
partner i'm not talking about for a
short term are we just gonna [ __ ] and
all that kind of stuff yeah
material let's say to women who have had
less experience less experience yes
100
sometimes less experience also means
wife material am i wrong yeah because i
feel like that's what he's saying okay
i feel like you contrasted that no no
yeah let's experience a man who knows a
woman who has had less penises inside
her vagina yeah is going to be his wife
more wife material so sorry are you okay
more wife material right 100 okay 100
but a woman who's had he's got 150 men
that she's slept with
men aren't like yeah that's wifey mm-hmm
even if she brings other qualities to
the table doesn't matter
but do you think i will let you i will
be honest men are that's why women lie
about their body count and that's why
men ask about the body count mm-hmm
women lie about their bodyguards i could
ask all women here about their body
count you would lie right now
but
but right there you go you're bad
ellen what'd you want to say
sorry i still have hiccups but do not
think that you know
it's okay i'm good
oh my god i'm guess i'm not good but do
you not think that like you know it's
like the same vice versa what do you
mean
like you know obviously
oh my god like we know like if a man
were to have experience
and you know like me listen to this but
you know maybe the woman's looking
for something else
okay
that's what i'm saying like you know
maybe like the woman is looking for
something more serious and because she
knows
that you've
but you've hooked up with like you know
all these multiple women whatever yeah
but that's attractive to a woman
generally you think so like to have
multiple sexual partners is attractive
it's a true woman do you know why
it's because a woman wants to know that
a man is experienced they want to know
that he knows what he's doing i feel
like that that is a hit or miss
so all right all right so then my
question becomes now my question becomes
do you want a virgin now do you want a
virgin man well obviously not but i'm
not saying that i want someone that's
[ __ ] like 200 men i mean woman i'm
like i'm sorry
that would be
that would be a man who's gay
but i always say that but but
there's there's there's there's
biological reasons for the reasons we
feel the way we feel so the reason that
women i'm gonna i'm gonna mute you
the reason the reasons why women are
attracted to men that have slept with
more women is because
like we want it was pre-selection so
before like we if a guy had a lot of
girls that was a sign
that he could take care of all those
women
so like we are biologically
predispositioned to like a man that has
been with like more girls
and i think that it's just
drinks drink some water i think that
for women
to have someone that's a virgin it's
just like a
oh it's like a sigh like dang they don't
know what they're doing because right it
takes for a man it doesn't take much to
please them for women it takes more
right he needs to know what the hell
he's doing right he doesn't have
experience is going to be like okay let
me
you're going to have to teach yeah
yeah it's just going to take longer and
i feel like more females don't want to
take that process to
like to
help them out in that and
for men it's like they don't
not related but you know maybe we should
no but the thing is like there's a
what's a term turning someone out like
you turn someone out yeah but also
define that for me no like a man there's
someone out there
not no i thought no okay i could could
be wrong but i thought it was a man who
gets with a woman who's kind of like oh
i'm shy
and he kind of makes her into like a
quote-unquote freak if that makes sense
okay okay yeah yeah yeah
like turning someone like so men would
prefer
to quote-unquote make that happen
then a woman would
try and make a man into
do you know what i mean a woman doesn't
want to teach a man yeah
yeah how to have sex because it's just
it's so much more for a female and it's
like
it's like
i might take you to sex ed to teach you
how to please me
exactly so men
understand that and so when men are
having
multiple sexual experiences in general
they understand that yeah so when they
get to a woman
and they've had multiple sexual
experiences they understand that that's
actually attractive to women
now
i'm not saying that
having multiple sexual experiences is a
good thing or a bad thing i'm just
saying
us as men we understand that if we come
to a woman
and we don't know what we're doing
she's probably going to be like
the [ __ ] is this guy yeah
there's biological reasons why we feel
the way we feel and we can't help like
you can't you can't really there's
biological reasons that we feel the way
we feel so we can't like necessarily
help it guys can't necessarily help that
they want more pure women especially in
this day and age i've had a lot of guys
wish they could turn that off
there are no pure women
oh god
okay
wait
like generally in the western world like
women like
no i don't generally think that men
i don't think women generally think men
are pure
and i don't generally think that women
think sorry men don't think women are
pure and women don't think men are
generally pure in this day and age you
know i mean the western culture yeah i
don't yeah no
like if when someone says oh i'm single
i'm like
how many men you got in your dms
but i don't lie like
that's not yeah
how many men you [ __ ] that's
available when was the last time you had